est ce qu'il ya un problème de la
télévision et de l'enfant c'est bien
difficile à dire
en tout cas s'il ya un problème de
consommation il me paraît simple souvent
des parents disent prendre savez c'est
terrible on n'arrive pas à les faire
démarrer de leur télévision et la
regarderai jusqu'à 11 heures du soir et
je réponds souvent à ces personnes
écoutées je pense que chez vous vous
avez du cognac une bouteille d'alcool
quelconque est-ce que vos enfants ont
droit d'en voir impunément
non bien sûr alors pourquoi ont-ils
droit de consommer impunément de la
télévision il faut créer une discipline
en tout la télévision comme on crée une
discipline autour de toutes les
activités de la ville et en ce qui
concerne des émissions pour les enfants
je crois pas qu'il ya un problème
particulier la seule chose que je
déplore moi c'est que les émissions pour
les enfants n'est pas le même volume que
les émissions pour les grandes personnes
si vous voulez que les émissions pour
les enfants n'est pas exactement les
moyens qu'on les émissions pour les
grandes personnes croient que ça viendra
un jour pourquoi je m'en plains c'est
parce que je pense que un enfant qui
voit une émission à 17h01 jeudi voit
aussi une émission à 21h mardi et il
doit ne pas très bien comprendre
pourquoi on a moins de décors moins de
personnel moins deux comédiens pour
faire une émission pour les enfants en
fait si vous voulez je crois que la
solution c'est qu'il n'y ait plus de
télévision pour les enfants télévision
pour les grandes personnes qu'il est
simplement une est grande et une bonne
révision un peu adapté à un public
particulier
le jeudi ou le mercredi en tout cas je
peux vous dire que c'est un public
exigeant mais fort sympathique m'excuser
du travail
non
je
bonjour nous voici à nouveau dans notre
studio des jeux du g10 dit bonjour aller
très fort on va essayer de passer un
après-midi à peu près convenable et
peut-être que vous avez la chance dans
les autres régions d'aller à la piscine
aller jouer au ballon
vous en avez de la chance bon regardez
donc la télévision et la télévision elle
commence avec son société à part entière
notre ami jean claude darnal le célèbre
auteur de buffalo bill
pierre bonjour jean claude trichet
bonjour